c'est vrai qu'on possède questions si
c'est pourquoi vraiment ça m'obsède pas
pourquoi je n'ai pas pu rester comme les
autres parce qu'en réalité ses seins ou
dis toujours aux gens pourquoi pourquoi
faites-vous de la peinture pourquoi
écrivez-vous pourquoi pourquoi
allez-vous rechercher les sources du nil
ou glamis hollywood ça n'a rien à voir
c'est pourquoi nous pas pu rester
d'ailleurs le bureau ou la vie vous a
placé pourquoi pourquoi votre champ à
labourer n'était pas ne vous a pas
rempli suffisamment et
je suis parti parce que
lorsque j'avais peur de devenir trop
vite me retrouver de vieux trop vite
j'ai eu envie de partir chercher de
partir physiquement leur surf quelque
chose et ce quelque chose
je n'ai pas trouvé les jeunes cherchent
encore
et c'est pour ça que je ne suis pas
encore bien du ltte